des paroles aux actes du moins si les
électeurs le veulent bien donc bon soir
dominique reynié consensus merci d'être
avec nous vous entrez donc dans la
bataille politique en rompant avec votre
métier de politologues de prof à
sciences po de commentateurs certes
engagé mais il ya évidemment une
montagne entre le commentaire et
l'action peut être demain vous êtes le
candidat de l'ump et de lui dis aux
élections régionales dans le
midi-pyrénées languedoc-roussillon donc
une vaste région qui verra le jour le
1er janvier de l'année prochaine et vous
nous direz ce qui vous motive ce qui
explique votre engagement aujourd'hui
comment vous allez mener lanka la
campagne et puis également qu'elles
seront éventuellement vos craintes de
novices même si peut-être votre volonté
d'incarner aujourd'hui le renouvellement
du personnel politique peut balayer tous
les doutes vous nous le dire et tout à
l'heure avec moi pour vous interroger
2000 dominique reynié il y aura
guillaume daudin de l' agence
france-presse qui est le partenaire de
prosper 3 comme chaque semaine et puis
perrine tarneaud de public sénat alors
évidemment dominique reynié on a tous
des racines paysannes 1 vous aussi vous
les exhumer j'ai vu pour ne pas passer
pour un taré cité
non c'est non c'est parce que c'est
comme je les dis j'ai été choisi au
terme d'une procédure unique
qui est qui a été mise en place par les
élus de la région
40 élus qui ont voulu choisir la tête de
liste ump dit ils m'ont choisi et donc
je dis on ne parachute pas depuis le sol
ça n'existe pas emma mes origines
aveyronnaises son sont importantes pour
moi donc c'est pas simplement c'est vrai
qu'on peut tout se dire qu'on a des
origines paysannes mais moi je viens
d'un
d'une petite ville de l'aveyron même si
c'est le chef-lieu rodez où je suis né
où j'ai grandi où j'ai passé mon bac
avant d'aller à toulouse pendant un an
faire les études d'histoire van dalen à
sciences po mais voilà je n'ai jamais
rompu avec ce qui est ma région mon
départ tous les cas comme nouveau venu
vous avez été bien accueillis
effectivement vous avez été désigné par
les 40 élus de la région souvent le
renouvellement est mal perçu mal vécue
par les élus qui sont déjà en place je
sais pas ce que vous avez vu si vous
avez vu ce qui s'est passé dans la
région voisine en l'aquitaine avec le
sort de virginie calmels ce1
l'ancienne productrice du loft qui se
divisait par des réflexions sexistes ou
méprisante alors sexistes à votre
rencontre peut-être pas mais méprisante
parfois non non non mais virginie
calmels s'était déjà élu au conseil
municipal si je me trompe pas moi je
n'ai encore exercer aucun mandat et sur
les dix candidats qui étaient présents
il était le seul à n'avoir exercé aucun
mandat et ce sont les élus qui n'ont
voulu en vous cette procédure et puis
ils m'ont choisi à la fin au terme d'une
campagne quand même un qui a duré
plusieurs semaines où j'ai vu tous ces
élus où j'ai beaucoup beaucoup visité la
région j'ai beaucoup parlé avec eux donc
c'est un vrai travail aussi de
persuasion est-ce que vous avez d'ores
et déjà une vision pour la future grande
région vous voulez présider demain oui
certainement certainement oui il ya
quelque chose au départ moi je les dis
cette fusion était une bonne idée la
méthode était épouvantablement mauvaise
et le but données étaient nulles et non
avenues ont dit on va faire une fusion
pour faire des économies y a pas pire
raison que celle là est donc ce que je
propose c'est qu'on fasse la fusion pour
faire de la croissance de l'emploi de
l'innovation de la solidarité entre les
territoires du développement durable de
notre priorité ce serait quoi ce sera
l'emploi emploi oui parce que la région
languedoc-roussillon qui va être
fusionnée avec midi-pyrénées a quasiment
15 % de chômeurs aujourd'hui vous êtes
au dessus de la moyenne nationale avec
une disparité évidemment entre les deux
régions et villes tendent aujourd'hui
absolument il ya du chômage en
midi-pyrénées
supérieur au niveau national mais mais
mais languedoc-roussillon ses deux
records en france est de 15% et encore
c'est la moyenne si on prend le chômage
chez les jeunes cette catastrophe mais
demain si vous avez les clés de cette
future grande région n'auraient pas les
clés totalement de la politique
économique vous ne pouvez pas par
exemple aujourd'hui promettent comme
d'autres l'inversion de la courbe du
chômage non la tâche de cette région
elle va faire beaucoup pour l'emploi
ainsi elle est bien pensé c'est pas un
conseil régional en plus grand c'est un
nouveau conseil régional et une de ses
fonctions et du président aussi ce sera
d'aller chercher partout dans le monde
des investisseurs partout dans le monde
de nouveaux marchés pour les producteurs
et donc cette dimension là qui va
occuper beaucoup
la nouvelle présidence de ce nouveau
conseil régional m'amène d'ailleurs à
considérer que ce sera une activité
essentielle à plein temps est d'accord
c'est la raison pour laquelle moi j'ai
annoncé et je demanderai aux autres de
le faire que je n'existerais aucune
autre activité que celle là et je
demanderai un autre mandat que celui là
pour être sûrs de leurs plans ou il faut
vous avez déjà regardé tous les chiffres
vous connaissez votre budget demain par
exemple je pense à ce retour de 3
milliards d'euros pour 1 milliard
d'euros ce qui n'est pas beaucoup mais
davantage cette région c'est qu'elle a
des coûts de fonctionnement qui seront
beaucoup plus faible la région est une
voyez vous commencez à parler quand même
d'économies non non je veux dire par là
que la région et y en a des coûts de
fonctionnement faible par rapport aux
départements ou même à certaines
communes son budget disponible pour
l'action est beaucoup plus important
qu'il n'y paraît si vous dites 3
milliards c'est pas beaucoup enfin parce
que sa façon de travailler qui m ² bon 5
millions six cent mille habitants c'est
pas beaucoup mais si vous en faites un
usage stratégique un effet de levier
pour aider l'investissement et de la
croissance là vous pouvez avoir plus les
fonds européens qui sont désormais
gérées par les conseils régionaux qui
représente à peu près une somme
équivalente cette réforme territoriale a
été présenté par le chef de l'état et
par le gouvernement par le premier
ministre quand même comme devant
déboucher sur des économies à plus ou
moins long terme est ce que vous vous y
engager ou dit que c'est mission
impossible
c'est pas lui c'est pas le but soit de
sympathie c'est une conséquence quand
même lorsqu'il arby's économie oui mais
avec cet empilement qui demeure
d'ailleurs un destin si on supprime
locaux collectivités et les mises si on
suit un conseil régional une entité avec
d'administration sur deux qu'est ce
qu'on va avoir comme économie à reilhac
du tout rien du tout pas du tout c'est
marginal en revanche si on fait la
fusion pour donner à cette région les
clés de sa croissance et de son emploi
on aura des ressources qui aujourd'hui
n'existe plus et ces ressources
permettront d'aller vers le progrès le
développement sans avoir besoin de
parler d'économies qui seront ridicules
et qui ne ramènent pas lieu je prends un
exemple simple les deux systèmes
informatiques des anciennes régions ne
sont pas cohérentes son parent monieux
et donc pour fusionner il va falloir
inventer un nouveau système investir ça
va coûter de l'argent vainqueur d'accord
mais je vois quand même que vous êtes un
adapté de compromis quand même le décret
n'est besoin je vois que vous ne voulez
pas par exemple montpellier se laisser
dépouiller par toulouse qui sera la
future capitale régionale alors quoi
vous allez garder comme ça deux entités
une préfecture un conseil régional à 240
km de distance c'est pas un compromis en
fait c'est que ce qu'il faut absolument
rester tuco non pas du tout pas du tout
ce qu'il faut éviter c'est que en fait
en réalité c'est que il y une région est
de vitesse et que du côté de midi
pyrénées qui est une région magnifique
avec un bassin d'emploi c'est le
troisième en france 92 mille emplois
l'aéronautique ne connais pas d'un côté
ça de l'autre côté languedoc roussillon
sans projet phare 100 projets de
croissance aujourd'hui on dit toulouse
l'aéronautique et montpellier ont dit
c'est quoi on ne sait pas répondre il va
falloir répondre je propose que le
conseil régional unique qui va demeurer
soit à montpellier que l'hôtel de région
soit montpellier mais ce n'est pas la
solution ça c'est un signe pour dire
n'oublions pas le languedoc-roussillon
faisons une fusion mais dans l'égalité
entre étant correctement les deux
régions et non pas en donnant en
oubliant l'une des deux qui n'aura donc
les gens limités de cette réforme
franchement d'ailleurs j'ai vu que le
parti socialiste était sur la même
position que vous enfin ou inversement
sur le maintien des deux entités le
parti socialiste dans la région
d'hambourg sur ne voulait pas de la
réforme forte majorité leur impose et ce
matin il y avait les principaux élus
socialistes notamment monsieur malvy
monsieur sorel le maire de montpellier
et monsieur larry le président de la
conduire ensemble d'appeler à la
résistance c'est la table qu'il soit
utilisé contre leur propre majorité
parce qu'il désapprouve la réforme donc
là c'est un peu confus mais ce sera à
eux de voir avec leurs portes magiques
vous avez une question d'une idée du nom
de la future grande région ce sera un
sujet très sensible
alors je veux dire par là que offrait
des propositions il y aura des
propositions de méthode c'est ça que je
veux dire parce que chacun peut avoir un
nom à l'esprit occitanie languedoc faut
pas oublier les catalans ils ouvrent ce
serait pas juste les oublier faut pas
non plus un nom qui soit fait par des
marketeurs soit vivant que ce soit
enracinée charnelle qu'on se
reconnaissent là dedans on fera des
propositions en fera une proposition de
méthode a pendant la campagne pour qu'on
puisse ensemble coproduire le nom de la
région d'accord alors j'ai vu en tous
les cas que midi pyrénées languedoc
roussillon on va sonner à la disposition
des de nos actes elle va devenir la
première région viticole au monde c'est
déjà une chose que vous pourrez
revendiquer de même souligner avec 273
mille hectares là est ce que vous pensez
que la fusion des territoires peut être
aussi des cépages sera la chose la moins
difficile à réaliser oui bah c'est une
région qui va des du foie gras aux
huîtres
normal qu'au passage au nez du vin et
c'est un des aspects importants de cette
région que d'être capable de soutenir le
développement d'une viticulture de
qualité puisque comme vous le savez
probablement le fait des efforts des
efforts considère qu'ils sont reconnus
aujourd'hui dans le monde arabe et
effectivement on exporte beaucoup les
vins de pays d'autres régions exactement
alors votre candidature encore une étape
à franchir oui ce sera sa validation par
la commission d'investiture de l'ump ce
sera jeudi vous aller répéter un petit
peu ce que vous avez dit aux élus locaux
je suis auditionnés oui donc je vais
répondre aux questions qui me seront
posées je trouve que la démarche
est normal
et donc je répondrai à leurs questions à
la fois sur l'évaluation de la situation
de la région sur le plan économique sur
le plan social les obstacles que la
fusion peut rencontrer les difficultés
qu'il faudra surmonter et puis aussi
comment gagner la région alors et cette
fois ça y est nicolas sarkozy vous
soutiens parce qu'on a lu des choses
contradictoires il n'y a jamais eu de
difficulté avec nicolas sarkozy il est
derrière votre dès le départ en fait je
peux vous le raconter si vous avez trois
secondes c'est pas bien mais lorsque ce
processus a été ouvert j'ai pensé que je
pouvais m'engager et donc j'ai fait
quelque chose de très simple c'est que
je suis allé le voir dans son bureau et
je lui dis voilà moi je souhaite
m'engager dans cette candidature si vous
me dites là maintenant que c'est pas une
bonne idée parce que vous avez prévu
quelque chose voilà je reste là à la
peine de compliquer la vie il m'a dit je
ne vous le dit pas et il m'a dit si vous
voulez faire de la politique il faut
être élu
vous pouvez poursuivre et je le dis est
ce que vous me permettez de dire que je
vous ai vu je me dis oui vous pouvez le
dire donc ce que je fais d'accord j'ai
considéré que s'il n'y a pas d'obstacle
si vous voulez quand même pas
d'encouragements donc c'était quand même
pas ça m'a pas découragé en tout cas non
mais voilà il a pas dit vas-y foncé fait
comme moi j'utilise mes méthodes on n'a
pas cette renault avait à l'époque je
pense à sa prise de neuilly par quick et
une prise
j'avais devant moi une campagne à mener
40 élus à convaincre c'était début mars
l'élection a eu lieu le 25 avril j'avais
beaucoup de kilomètres à parcourir
beaucoup de monde à voir ce que j'ai
fait pour être élu ensuite en 4 mt
maintenant il a manifesté plus d'entrain
pour votre candidature maintenant vous
avez franchi lui coûter une première
étape il m'a téléphoné le nahd qui a
suivi mon élection à 7 pour me féliciter
chaleureusement et c'était là c'était un
moment sympa donc vous avez aussi estimé
vous gagnez votre légitimité auprès du
président de l'ump auprès des élus aussi
auprès du professeur
majid puisqu'au pour après tout quand je
suis entré dans son bureau j'étais un
politologue qui n'avait jamais essayé
d'être évident cette manière là donc là
je les fais j'ai montré que je pouvais
le faire j'ai fait des kilomètres j'ai
convaincu j'ai débattu j'ai discuté
j'argumente et j'ai été auditionné j'ai
gagné ce scrutin assez largement donc je
pense qu'il s'est dit mais voilà il sait
faire d'accord voilà bon alors est-ce
que vous avez pris votre carte à l'ump
vous allez nous le dire dans un espace
vide greniers guillaume daudin de
l'agencé france presse va nous rejoindre
maintenant mais on va d'abord voir
l'enjeu du congrès qu'est l'ump convoque
à la fin du mois sandra cerqueira
les républicains c'est le nom qui fâche
un peu tout le monde à l'ump pour les
proches d'alain juppé notamment ceux
nommés ainsi s'est vidé la république de
son sens et donc source de clivage alors
pour mettre fin aux critiques nicolas
sarkozy a décidé de faire voter les
adhérents de nicolas sarkozy va se fier
tout le monde et que les décisions ne
sont pas contestables
à partir de ce moment là il vient il
propose ce vote qui n'était pas prévu au
départ mais je crois que c'est la
meilleure idée comme ça il n'y aura pas
de rabat joie à l'issue de ce vote mais
vouloir changer de nom à tout prix n'est
ce pas un peu trop risqué car le
résultat du vote des militants tombera
la veille du congrès du 30 mai s'il est
négatif cela pourrait venir enrayer la
dynamique de renouveau du parti et même
mettre nicolas sarkozy en échec mais
chez les proches on cherche à rassurer
ce congrès sera bien celui du renouveau
un congrès de refondation pour passer de
250 mille cinq cent mille adhérents très
vite pour faire un grand parti populaire
républicain qui fera de la république le
coeur de son dispositif politique le
coeur de son projet et je pense que
c'est ce que les gens attendent pas su à
l'alternance l'alternance à l'ump on n'a
que ce mot à la bouche c'est sur la
refondation du parti et l'étape clé vers
la reconquête du pouvoir autre étape les
régionales fin 2015 pour bruno
retailleau tête de liste de la droite
dans les pays de la loire pas de doute
ces élections seront un vrai test
national
regardez d'ailleurs au relais
départemental jamais
jamais je n'avais vu des départementales
aussi nationaliser avec des thèmes
nationaux aussi prégnant avec treize
régions métropolitaines seulement la
dimension nationale de cette élection
sera très très affirmée enjeu national
en vue de la présidentielle de 2017 et
une démonstration de force obligé de la
droite face au front national dans
quelques régions comme dans le languedoc
roussillon ou en région paca le fn est
une sérieuse menace
voilà et guillaume daudin de la sp nous
a rejoint mais koné vos questions
bonsoir
le suspense est insoutenable vous allez
parler donc de prendre votre carte à
l'ump où en êtes-vous je les fais ça y
est mais je les fais je l'avais promis
au moment où je me suis engagée en cas
d'investiture
les partis politiques sont nécessaires
c'est pas seulement l'article 4 de la
constitution
aller vers une élection voilà ça suppose
d'être avec un parti politique donc je
les fais ça y est donc et vous allez
peut-être reprendre dans quelques
semaines la carte cette fois des
républicains oui c'est possible que si
vous pensez de ce nom vous le l'ex
politologue on peut dire désormais oui
je là aussi on en parlera mais vous
c'est un traitement asymétrique dont son
kiki réservé à ceux qui font de la
politique à droite puisqu'on peut être
un politologue quand on a été élu au
parti socialiste en reste kuito loeb
mais à droite on est un ex politologue
c'est une caractéristique français avant
avec laquelle je vis délivrera oui
absolument j'ai des collègues qui sont
quittés quand on reviendra monsieur
bergougnoux ses salles à l'historien des
voix olivier duhamel est ce qu'on le dit
que c'est un ex politologue il a été élu
socialiste jacques générale économie de
sciences po candidat sur la liste du
front de gauche est toujours un
économiste et pas un ex économiste mais
c'est une c'est une habitude française
et ce à cause de rupture mais vous en
parlais tout à l'heure avec ces tunnels
vraiment je pense que rice et vous un
avant et un après bien sûr
une asymétrie française qui est lié je
crois un héritage de l'après 1945 c'est
une question intéressante mais sur sur
vème république moi j'ai dit tout de
suite que j'ai trouvée avant même
d'ailleurs de m'engager j'ai dit que
c'était une bonne idée d'accord c'est
une très bonne idée d'abord parce que
changer de nom c'est marquer le
changement de cycle et là c'est une
nécessité si on veut refonder quelque
chose il faut un nouveau nom sortir du
sigle c'est une bonne idée aussi que ce
soit parlant ump est un sigle qui ne
parlent pas c'est une bonne idée d'avoir
un contenu substantiel et les
républicains c'est une formule que je
trouve impeccable je ne vois pas du tout
ce que l'on peut reprocher la formule
elle est parfaite les critiques on les
avait entendus certains parlent de
captation d'héritage la plupart des
partis politiques français pourrait se
dire se présenter comme les républicains
vous êtes très jeune mais le
rassemblement pour la république n'avait
pas à ce moment-là soulevé de critiques
de ce genre à aimer la république l
agrément avec une prétention exclusivité
quand même reconnaissait d'ailleurs on
peut on peut s'appeler moment je ne
crois pas du tout je travaille toutefois
qu'on vous ait affirmé enfin je pense
que l'intention est d'affirmer
l'attachement aux valeurs de la
république et là il me semble que c'est
quelque chose qui fait sens et qui
d'ailleurs donne à cet ancien ump une
orientation philosophique et politique
qui a une importance qu'il faut
souligner et je dirais même reconnaître
on vous parlait les valeurs de la
république vous êtes candidat dans une
région où se situe béziers la ville dont
elle est maire robert ménard il aurait
ficher les élèves selon leur religion
supposée qu'est ce que vous en pensez
alors donc êtes journaliste il faudra
faire attention que tout ça soit vérifié
je suis pas en mesure même de le dire je
n'ai pas d'information donc c'est
toujours un peu compliqué mais il est
évident que ce type de pratique ne peut
que susciter l'indignation les
dénonciations fait c'est scandaleux il
n'y a pas de mots on peut utiliser à
part celui là c'est violent et il faut
bien comprendre le défi de la différence
entre
chercher à avoir des informations
statistiques sur des sur les individus
ce que moi je souhaite par exemple on
n'est pas assez renseignée en france
société française sa complexité sa
composition ce qu'on appelle les
statistiques ethniques moi j'en suis je
suis favorable mais ça veut dire ça que
l'on fait des recensements et qu'on
renseigne parce que parce que les gens
vous déclare être eux-mêmes librement
l'apparemment et pas de ce qu'elle l'a
apparemment on impute à quelqu'un une
religion ou une identité sans lui
demander son avis sans avoir sont
concentrés en fonction d'un prénom en
fonctionnement donc c'est un acte
violent autoritaire inacceptable
évidemment et qui d'ailleurs doit nous
rappeler que ce type de parti politique
a quand même cette mentalité au coeur de
ce qu'il est et il ne faudrait pas qu'il
ait le pouvoir avec les outils qu'on
vient de lui donner aujourd'hui parler
du projet
cc outils spécifiques pour la
surveillance c'est très bien quand vous
avez des démocrates et des républicains
qui les ont indiqué qu'ils ont entre les
mains mais quand vous avez un parti qui
est d'une nature d'une culture
différente vous prenez un risque
considère députés ump à l'assemblée
nationale vous n'auriez pas voté par
exemple je le pense que je leur ai
beaucoup beaucoup amendé en tout cas
j'aurai essayé de l'amendé beaucoup
c'est un texte qui dont je comprends
l'intention parce qu'on a un vrai sujet
de sécurité donc ça on peut pas le nier
ce serait absurde mais je trouve qu'il
va très loin et que peut-être demain et
qu'il est liberticide
il réduit en tout cas est liberticide
s'est formé il ya du beau coup les
libertés en tout cas votre crâne
première c'est qu'il tombe demain entre
des régimes qui ne serait pas forcément
démocratique il faut écouter c'est quand
vous avez des outils pareil vous avez
deux risques que demain une crise nous
oblige à l'utiliser de façon excessive
ou nous amène à l'utiliser de façon
excessive ou que des gouvernants qu'ils
soient moins en public et que d'autres
et bien en face à un usage qui serait
qui serait terrible pour reprendre ce
vocabulaire vous vous êtes plutôt
fichiers comme libérale et vous êtes
vous venez de le dire favorables à des
statistiques ethniques je suis pas sûr
que ça fasse dans votre camp l'unanimité
la possibilité d'ouvrir des statistiques
ethniques c'est un sujet vous savez
c'est un sujet qui divise droite et
gauche moi je les leur là pour le coup
je le dis que c'est pas trés c'est pas
une comment dire une mesure qui colle
trop à l'image les républicains
justement je sais pas moi moi je sais
très simple je ne peux pas je crois
aujourd'hui en france avoir une idée de
ce que nous sommes ni des problèmes que
nous rencontrons si on ne fait pas cela
je prends un exemple très simple on ne
peut pas nous parler d' inégalités
sociales liées aux origines ethniques
des individus s'il n'y a pas ce genre de
statistiques ce sont des imputations ou
des spéculations sans fondement moi je
crois que ça existe les inégalités mais
prouve on le montre aurait dû alors
effectivement trop lourd fait qu'il ya
des inégalités dues aux origines je
pense au fait qu'on est un immigré au
fait qu'on porte un nom à consonance
arabe au fait qu'on habite un quartier
chivu l'immigration les plus fortes et
vous avez là effectivement tunis ré de
conséquences qui en découlent et qui
pose des problèmes voilà dans notre pays
et qu'il faut arriver à courrier et
inversement inversement savoir s'il y a
plus de délinquance liés à l'immigration
ou pas comment le sait-on sans ce team
statistiques donc on a vraiment là un
problème d'information je précise juste
que régler des questions qui se posent
des difficultés ou bien pour encourager
des revendications communautaristes
ça peut être ça aussi l'autre versant
non si l'on peut parler on peut pas
gouverner un pays qu'on ne connaît pas
c'est impossible moi je sais plus sur la
société britannique hollandaise
américaine grâce aux statistiques de ces
pays là que sur ma propre société en
tant que politologue je ne sais plus et
non pas être ainsi plus vous voyez donc
c'est c'est quand même d'erreurs on peut
pas on peut pas je dirais je pense même
contesté la nécessité de ces dossiers
tous ces outils d'accord vous êtes
candidat en octobre en languedoc
roussillon aussi on me dit pyrénées
c'est surtout en languedoc roussillon
une région le front national fait des
grosses cornes vous avez dénoncé à
plusieurs reprises le populisme vous
avez même écrit un livre sur la pente
fatale du populisme et pourtant vous
rejoignez un parti dont le dirigeant
actuel nicolas sarkozy a été accusé
d'être le l'un des principaux promoteurs
de d'être celui qui pousse les français
peut-être le plus dans cette pente
est-ce qu'il ya par un grand écart
il ya quelques minutes vous me disiez il
s'appelle les républicains et capte
l'héritage donc moi je sais ça c'est du
marketing après peut-être sur le fond
c'est un procès d'intention et oui dans
l'est c'est
un parti qui s'appelle les républicains
si c'est la preuve qu'il ne l'est pas ça
devient compliqué moi je crois que de
manière très claire et cela s'est vu y
compris aux élections départementales et
aux élections municipales et c'est pas
par hasard que ça va s'appeler
républicain j'imagine il ya une ligne
qui a été fixé et est qui et qui a pas
d'alliance avec le front national je
crois le nom est un garde-fou en quelque
sort en tout cas c'est une grosse ça
vous oblige ensuite c'est très difficile
quand on s'engage c'est pas rien c'est
pas un changement de marque comme on
peut changer de marque pour un produit
un parti qui va s'appeler les
républicains je crois que le signe est
très clair pour ce qui concerne la
période qui aurait au moins jusqu'en
2017 il ya un engagement qui est qui et
prix public extrêmement affirmé qui va
contraindre les acteurs et qui déjà je
crois moi définit une certaine campagne
qui sera très différente des campagnes
précédant d'accord ce que pendant les
dans la campagne récente par exemple
pour les départementales nicolas sarkozy
sait a soutenu le maire je crois que
c'était chalon sur saône qui s'était qui
avait critiqué qui avait interdit dans
sa ville les repas de substitution dans
les cantines sans porc c'est peut-être
justement quelque chose qui y
participent de cette pente populiste
ça c'est un grand débat parce que
quelqu'un peuvent aussi vous dire et je
pense même qu'il ya là c'est vraiment on
voit les différentes générations entre
vous et moi parce qu'il ya il ya 15 ans
20 ans on aurait pu défendre cette
position au nom de la laïcité
républicaine
c'est ce qui c'est ce qui est fait par
nicolas sarkozy est aujourd'hui voyons
on peut encore le sentiment aujourd'hui
à vous écouter que cette position elle
est anti républicaine alors qu'elle est
ultra laïque est peut-être trop laïque
mais elle est ultra laïque et du coup
elle est très république mais là vous
revenez dans votre position de
commentateurs mais qu'est ce que vous en
pensez justement vous moi je suis pour
la république laïque et pour la laïcité
je considère ça c'est très simple je les
dis récemment devant lui lui dit lors de
la dernière convention nationale il
m'avait demandé de plancher la dessus on
a tous les outils en france pour
affirmer la nature laïc de notre
république on les a les outils il faut
les appliquer il faut les faire
respecter il ne faut pas se laisser
envahir par un débat qui nous amènerait
ce qui serait mon avis catastrophique à
rouvrir la question de la laïcité et
voir comment on peut la réaménager là je
pense qu'on prendrait un grand risque
nous avons tous les outils qu'il faut
donc nous pouvons avec sa gouverner
cette question du religieux dans
l'espace public
au fond avec ce genre de position vous
êtes un peu plus proche de juppé qui
veut être prudent sur ces questions que
que de nicolas sarkozy qui préfère
affirmer les principes fortement et j'ai
dit moi aux journalistes qui m'ont
interrogé comme vous sur ces questions
là j'ai dit que les questions qui ne
m'intéressait pas et que je n'y
répondrai pas parce que pourquoi parce
que moi j'ai d'avoir 55 ans je tente un
premier mandat 55 ans refuse de répondre
à certaines questions moi je les pose
vous êtes maintenant militants de l'ump
on a envie de savoir
des personnes qui sait internationl idée
c'est pas ça moi je me serais moi je moi
je comprends la question mais comprenez
ma réponse mon chemin il est pas là je
rentre par les élections régionales dans
ma région il ya tant à faire si ça rate
c'est une catastrophe pour ma région et
ce que je veux dire aux électeurs de ma
région 4 millions 100 mille c'est voilà
ce que l'on peut faire pour réussir la
grande région c'est essentiel et on l'a
trop souvent trop souvent parler aux
électeurs de questions qui ne sont pas
impliqués par l'élection si vous voulez
notamment de questions un peu
stratosphérique ou conceptuelles ou très
polémiques qui n'ont pas de lien avec le
geste qu'on leur demande d'accomplir
venez choisir un conseil régional eh
bien ils ne voient plus leurs la
relation qu'il ya entre des controverses
nationales et une élection locale ils ne
votent pas et c'est une catastrophe aux
dernières élections départementales dans
la grande région 2 millions et
abstentionnistes 2 millions alors que
vous avez vu certains de vos amis de vos
nouveaux amis monsieur retailleau qu'on
a entendues a rappelé qu' il y avait un
enjeu derrière l'enjeu local
y'en à 2017 essayer de voilà de changer
de majorité au sein de votre région vous
êtes encore engagée au niveau national
sus également national dominique reynié
est là où monsieur retailleau a raison
c'est que les résultats des élections
régionales auront une répercussion sur
l'évaluation que l'on va faire du
résultat futur en 2017 comme on l'a fait
pour les départementales ou les
municipales ça c'est tout à fait sont
les élections intermédiaires dont vous
êtes engagés dans l'alternance nationale
moi je suis candidat dans une région qui
est ou dont les deux parties d'un futur
grandes régions sont socialistes donc je
le souhaite ardemment l'alternance moi
même je vais d'obtenir ce que j'ai dit
depuis les villes ce qui se fera ça veut
dire que vous pensez que ni françois
hollande en 2017
ça va être difficile pour lui il encore
une chance
dans ma région il a perdu voilée sur le
plan national c'est plus difficile a
perdu dans votre région c'est que il a
fortiori rendu au volant d'une déduction
que je suis d'accord avec un commentaire
sur le front national puisqu'on revient
sur notamment voter voter oui parce que
vous êtes donc cette décision assez
assez marquée par le front national et
notamment par louis aliot qui sera qui
sera le candidat
par l'adversaire le vise c'est quand
c'est votre adversaire vous voilà vous
vous êtes plutôt vous êtes plutôt
fichiers gelé dite s'élève libéral ou en
tout cas on vous colle cette étiquette
comment vous allez faire campagne voilà
entre une gauche qui finalement dans
votre région est forte et un front
national qui progresse avec cette
étiquette de libéral moi je les dis je
veux dire la couleur politique de ma
région c'est l'abstention 2 millions
d'abstentionnistes à dire papa la
caractérise pas c'est beaucoup de
régions sont comme ça les deux millions
d'abstentionnistes
ce sont des millions d'électeurs qui ne
votent pas front national et qui ne sont
pas contents et donc on peut parler à
ses électeurs et on peut gagner une
élection en parlant des problèmes qui
font voter front national sans
nécessairement parler du front national
louis aliot faire la campagne qui de on
écoutera ses propositions chat curieux
de savoir ce qu'il propose donc cette
fusion soit réussi et pour qu'on sorte
du chômage qui frappe aujourd'hui le
languedoc-roussillon je renais tam
enclos de savoir comment on va faire
pour sortir cette région du chômage en
la fermant au monde puisque cette région
doit tout ce qu'elle a ou presque tous
aujourd'hui aux exportations 92 millions
airbus troisième site d'emploi en france
autour de toulouse donc c'est cela qui
va falloir discuter c'est pas les
voiliers les grandes envolées lyriques
facile à faire sur le sur les candidats
pour essayer de discréditer ou de les
dénigrer ça c'est très facile de
s'attaquer sur le programme à huy
néanmoins dernière question est ce que
vous redoutez que la rupture fracassante
de marine le pen avec son père
finalement favorise la marche en avant
de la présidente du fn ah ça c'est très
curieux parce que moi j'ai le sentiment
est ce que vous redoutez non moi j'ai le
sentiment d'une histoire familiale
impudique proche du vulgaire qui
aujourd'hui montre que ce parti est une
entreprise personnelle qui n'a aucune
dimension pour gouverner alors même pas
un département même pas un avenir
national là il va falloir quand même
qu'ils sortent de leurs querelles
familiales qui sont ce qu elle n'est pas
justement en train d'en sortir
actuellement je ne crois pas non
seulement le bayer je ne crois pas je ne
pense pas que le père se laisse faire et
puis je sais pas comment ce sera
apprécié par des radiers toute façon
mais
peut-on peut-on me donner un exemple de
notre parti politique dont on tolérer un
tel comportement qui depuis des mois se
dispute entre le père la fille la petite
fille le genre du père enfin on s'y perd
et ça dure et ça dure et aujourd'hui on
a l'impression que le psychodrame monte
en intensité
on le perd exige que la fille change de
nom enfin on est d'ordre le grotesque et
l'épée ça dépend sur quoi c'est un parti
qui est déconsidéré je ne sais pas
comment les électeurs vont considérer
que ce parti là est capable de leur
apporter une solution à leur problème ça
me paraît être une démonstration
éclatante merci guillaume perrine
tarneaud de public sénat arrive
maintenant dominique reynié juste après
cette enquête de samia de sheer sur sur
ceux qui comme vous ont basculé un jour
dans la politique dans la vie politique
active en se présentant devant les
électeurs
la politique en france est devenu l'
affaire de professionnels souvent
indéboulonnable il y a ceux qui en font
leur carrière et d'autres qui viennent
beaucoup plus tard noël mamère lui a
d'abord été journaliste pendant une
quinzaine d'années avant de devenir
député la politique française souffre
justement terriblement du manque
d'engagement de la société civile c'est
à dire de ces hommes et de ces femmes
qui
ont un métier qui vont l'exercer pendant
vingt-cinq ou trente ans et qui à un
moment de leur vie souhaitent s'engager
d'une autre manière dans leur société et
souvent ces personnes la rencontre des
barrières les barrières et les coûts que
réservent les partis politiques jean
marie cavada les connaît bien
journaliste puis directeur de plusieurs
grands médias il s'est d'abord engagé
chez les centristes dont il s'est
aujourd'hui éloigné pour prendre la
présidence du parti nous citoyen quand
on vient de la société civile qu'on n'y
a une autorité et qu'on rentre dans un
parti dans un premier temps on et
dorlotés comme l'enfant qui vient de
naître dans un deuxième temps beaucoup
de manoeuvres tente à vous pousser dans
les coins je mets en garde notre ami
monsieur régnier qui est un politologue
de que j'estime
mais ne m'attends sans doute pas pour
avoir vu cette chose-là et par
conséquence c'est une chose qui existe
il faut le savoir
de temps en temps dans l'impression
concert de force d'appoint
observateurs de premier plan de la vie
politique les politologues peuvent être
tentés de franchir le pas mais peu osent
comme dominique reynié se lancer dans
l'aventuré c'est un pari risqué que
prend dominique reynié connaît très bien
la vie politique il a des convictions
qui ne date pas d'aujourd'hui
libérale pro européenne
il a toujours été très critique à
l'égard des rapprochements de certains à
l'égard de certaines thèses du front
national
donc c'est un choix qui est tout à fait
légitime
courageux dans le passé les politologues
les observateurs les insectes ont eu du
mal à s'ancrer durablement dans la vie
politique un pari risqué car pour un
observateur de la vie politique
le retour en arrière est difficilement
envisageable
un bon soir perrine tarneaud question
donc à dominique reynié engagés on l'a
vu dans un pari risqué oui à paris c'est
ce que c'est un aller sans retour oui
forcément oui parce que on peut parvenir
ces faits diable l'état que j'ai quitté
je peux pas le retrouver je suis
maintenant quelqu'un qui sait qu'ils
s'engagent donc ya pas de vous êtes
jetés dans l'eau de la politique ouais
c'est ce que c'est un pari risqué oui
bien sûr si vous échouez évidemment oui
c'est un risque mais ça ça c'est le
c'est ce qui fait aussi si vous voulez
l'intérêt de ma démarche en tout cas à
mes yeux si je peux dire c'est que je
sors d'une situation où la qui était la
mienne et je j'entends
liste commentateurs et je rentre dans un
monde qui est différent où la bagarre
est rude
et c'est normal parce que voilà les
électeurs doivent choisir entre les
candidats et choisir le meilleur donc il
faut de meilleurs vous connaissez bien
effectivement ce milieu de la politique
et qui est dur pour en prendre un peu
les propos de jean-marie cavada au début
on et dorlotés un peu comme un enfant et
puis après il ya les coups oui bon qu'il
faut donner aussi parfois oui il faut
savoir savoir qu'il faut savoir recevoir
oui mais en même temps si vous voulez là
encore une fois moi je suis je suis je
viens en politique à 54 ans quand même
donc c'est pas bon je viens en politique
par une procédure qui déjà est une forme
de rite de passage si vous voulez un
désign et voilà la campagne que j'ai dû
faire etc j'ai dû écrire il ya une
primaire et puis le jour d'élection il y
avait vraiment y avait un suspense quoi
je sais pas eu quatre tours c'était très
tendu c'était formidable donc là il ya
quelque chose rémy et quatre tours est
ce que vous vous chantez légitimé pour
pour autant oui bah je t'ai c'était
prévu mais la procédure est organisé et
certains ne désarme pas tout à fait vous
le savez peut-être même pourrait
envisager une liste contre vous de
passer certains c'est un à tous vos
collègues me disent par exemple un et je
n'ai pas cité le sénateur jean-pierre
mais toujours est il que vous vous êtes
attendus au tournant parce que ce soit
c'est la victoire et alors là on sait la
naissance d'un animal politique soit
c'est d'échec et ce sera facile de te
dire que vous avez perdu parce que
finalement vous êtes amené e à vous
d'être un débutant en politique là on
peut avoir différents vins tout cas vous
avez raison nous allons vous avez raison
ça c'est sûr sur le fait que si on perd
après on dirat bon là c'était le mauvais
choix mais il ya des jeux qui est sans
doute très clair pour les
téléspectateurs c'est que si on fait
comme vous l'avez dit ce mouvement que
je considère comme irréversible si on
prend ce risque est réel même si bon
parce que pas quand même ma vie
exagérant rien c'est parce qu'on a la
conviction que l'on va gagner c'est tout
à fait ça que j'ai un esprit est
véritablement c'est cette conviction la
qui fait que mon chemin me paraît
désormais 3 c'est une confiance en vous
non c'est parce que la procédure déjà et
de premier acte qu'il fallait accomplir
pour gagner cette région je les lis
d'ailleurs osé dieu c'est là qu'ils ont
inventé je peux facilement ensuite parce
qu'une figure ici la société civile
comme moi correspond je le vois tous les
jours je suis beaucoup maintenant dans
la région et on me le dit la réception
est très positive très positive et enfin
parce que c'est le début oui mais si
vous êtes une personnalité un petit peu
nouvelle peut-être sur le terrain mais
on vous découvre c'est vraiment les
électeurs peuvent être ingrat et cela
s'est vite soit c'est possible mais là
pour le moment les gens sont très
heureux tous cas ce qu'ils me le disent
sont tout heureux de voir un nouveau
venu dans le monde politique ils le
demandent souvent c'est à dire pourquoi
les élèves étant donné cette procédure
est encore une fois sur dix candidats le
seul mot et lui c'est moi il me
choisissent c'est parce qu'ils ont
eux-mêmes conscience à travers leurs
expériences et leurs discussions avec le
rédacteur qu'il ya un besoin de
renouveau comment on passe de l'analyse
à l'action sa et étoile le point de
bascule finalement le point de bascule
il est que dans mon travail d'analyste
ça fait pas mal d'années maintenant que
je mets l'accent sur des difficultés que
notre pays rencontre
ça m'a préoccupé puis samarie qui était
je suis aujourd'hui dans maman très
très inquiet sur ce qui peut arriver à
ce pays que je trouve très fragile et
l'idée de continuer à tenir la chronique
de cette crise et cette fragilité assad
mais ça ne va plus du tout je me dis ou
bien j'arrête de commenter ce que faut
que je trouve autre chose parce que
c'est pas possible c'est insupportable
franchement à ce portable ou bien
j'essaie d'agir avec celles et ceux qui
agissent et donc je m'engage pour en
espérant faire mieux être et les autres
en politique il fera bon en maison vous
teniez jusqu'à présent la chronique
finalement un peu pessimiste en ainsi
clairement être utile par le fait que
ayant l'expérience que j'ai le parcours
que j'ai eue jusqu'ici je peux les aider
avec l'oph a pas tout seul pour les
aider à réaliser deux ou trois choses
qui seraient considérés comme et bien
une réponse positive aux difficultés de
leurs concitoyens qu'il y ait cette idée
que l'on peut réenchanter la démocratie
que l'on peut retrouver du côté de la
puissance publique une efficacité une
réponse si nous ne répondons pas à cette
attente là nous aurons une grande
désillusion aux élections prochaines on
pensait que ça me donne un peu une
longueur d'avancé finalement d'avoir été
un observateur de cette vie politique ça
vous donne un recul que n'ont peut-être
pas certains hommes politiques sur le
terrain peut-être par temps de crise
encore que je ne pas généraliser parce
que beaucoup d'élus connaissent bien
leur territoire lorsqu'ils sont réélus
ils le prouvent mais en tout cas le fait
d'être issu de la société civile même
sans doute une longueur d'avancé par
rapport à nos concurrents qui sont quand
même des politiques habitué aux mandats
et qui sont depuis toujours un dans la
politique là je pense que j'ai un
avantage sur eux alors déjà j'ai vu
qu'on sortait un peu tout votre
déclaration passée par exemple aux
prises opposition sur l'entrée au nom de
la turquie dans l'union européenne vous
êtes plutôt pour sur la gpa vous êtes
plutôt pour vous connaissiez donc votre
privilège de commentateurs politiques
est-ce que vous perdez aujourd'hui votre
liberté de parole notamment prenant
votre carte à l'ump chiens non mais moi
j'ai été entre 2008 et aujourd'hui
en dix minutes on m'a confié la
direction d'un think tank fondation pour
l'innovation politique
c'est quoi la fonction d'une telle
fondation c'est de faire tourner les
idées de gamberger de faire travailler
des experts et donc il est normal
c'était ma mission est d'ailleurs on a
réussi puisque pour la deuxième année on
est classée meilleure fondation
politique de france par un milieu de
pennsylvania pris des positions mais je
vais les reproches non mais attendez je
n'ai pas dit que je sais pas excusé j'y
serais dit que c'était un travail
directeur d'un think tank qui avait pour
mission de faire seulement de faire
c'est que les dés étaient d'accord
d'assumer certains mais on les a portés
en 2011 pour les pour les élus mais ce
que vous ne faites pas d'un candidat est
ce qu'en pense et la chaussée quoi s'en
garder une marge de manoeuvre de de
penser une liberté de parole ont
évidemment évidemment oui ça c'est des
je comprends pas moi je comprends la
question mais je comprends pas comment
voulez vous que ces sujets là et leurs
places dans les élections régionales
bell elles auront une place c'est vos
opposants par exemple chez les chevaux
opposants et puis dans le quotidien des
français des citoyens des élus
des régions même si les
régions la question de savoir s'il va
quand même être très nationale pour ces
régionales trade moi je les pense comme
en régions soit symboliquement c'est que
je ne pense pas seulement locale je
pense par exemple à la question
européenne sera abordée forcément vous
avez une position fédéraliste je suis
pro européen pro européens ils me
paraissent vers complètement dépassés
aujourd'hui dépassée pro européen
d'accord je toujours les crises de sont
des enjeux qui seront donc nourrir les
débats lors de la campagne des
régionales ce qui sont anti européens
nous expliquera aux motifs on sent les
fonds européens qui vont représenter 3
milliards et demi d'euros par la région
moi je veux bien tout ça c'est de la
théorie s'ils voulaient c'était quand
même trop mais l'édition sur leur insu
nationale nationaux si vous avez tort
franchement j'avais tort la complexité
je reconnais plus grande mais les
questions que vous posez que tous les
journalistes posent qui ne se la pose
parce qu'on me les pose jamais et ça
suppose pas de travail et surtout aller
voir les sujets régionaux qui est des
sujets majeurs en termes de santé en
termes de transport en termes
d'éducation de création d'emplois c'est
plus compliqué mais ça intéresse
beaucoup plus ses électeurs sur les
délocalisations on vous en parlera
peut-être bien sûr nous en parlera et on
y répondra mais je veux dire la question
de savoir des aeros derniers ont été en
2004 pour la turquie dans l'europe ça
franchement c'est stratosphérique nanon
messager cité des olympiens qui l'avait
cité ces mois après on me dit c'est
c'est vraiment un stratosphérique et
c'est un jeu politicien qui voudraient
de les sortir je suis pas dedans mais
qui mêle journalistes et politiques dans
un débat très parisien je vous assure
c'est une erreur ça les personnes va
s'intéresser à ça c'est pour ça que vous
avez des millions d'intentionnistes mais
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour les 15 % de
chômeurs de la région languedoc
roussillon c'est pas ça qui va répondre
à leurs questions est ce que quand même
après on parlait de populisme tout à
l'heure dans la deuxième partie de
l'émission est-ce qu'on campagne sur le
terrain sur les marchés il n'y a pas un
risque parfois de basculer dans la
parole facile dans la compromission
compromission c'est grave comme dans le
populisme populisme s'il salue aussi oui
mais je ne sais pas moi je ça c'est
quelque chose que vous découvrez vous
sur le terrain moi je veux des gens qui
me pas j'ai passé quatre jours dimanche
dernier j'étais à 7 sur le marché de 9
heures à 15 heures donc j'ai rencontré
des dizaines de personnes
on a eu beaucoup de discussions
on m'a parlé d'emplois demandait ce
qu'allait devenir le port de sète est ce
qu'on pouvait développer son activité ce
qu'on peut les faire revenir plus de
joker on vous parle
du problème où il arme problème européen
ou pas le problème des quotas pour les
tons puisque c'est 40% delà du quota du
temps d'arrêt donc vous avez des
questions très concrètes qui sont posées
il faut y répondre auquel vous savez
répondre il faut répond pas tout c'est
sûr mais il faut y répondre en tout cas
mais je vois pas là dedans
de risque populiste en fait populisme
c'est pas un risque c'est une tentation
c'est la tentation de celles et ceux qui
n'ont pas envie de travailler et qui
plutôt que de répondre aux questions qui
se posent ont envie de faire des
formules faciles ou d'en discuter au cas
font tous les jours la difficulté ou
d'en discuter comment ils ont discuté et
c'est ce qu'on fait tous ensemble quand
on parle de sujets qui n'intéressent pas
les électeurs ont fait tous du populisme
c'est facile on peut en parler mais
malheureusement ça ne répond pas aux
questions qu'ils se posent sur le
terrain vous avez un mentor en politique
ben je ne viens pas l'esprit à donc
voilà il faudrait que je remonte très
loin très très loin mais vous pouvez
aussi je ne sais pas j'appelle motors
n'ont pas de la question est
intéressante je m'étais jamais posé
alors est ce que vous avez prévu de
demander des conseils à certains mais je
demande beaucoup de conseils bien sûr
mais les ai dit les élus locaux qui
m'ont qui m'ont désigné en plus marrant
ma rencontre avec le était une rencontre
à la recherche de conseils
jean marc pujol le maire de perpignan
jean luc moudenc le maire de toulouse je
sais par les marques sénateurs dans la
maison s'engager avec vous dans la
campagne oui bien sûr oui monsieur mais
parce que le fait de gagner la région a
une importance scrutin vous savez ce
sont des élections de fondation il n'y a
pas de sortant il faut fabriquer une
nouvelle région les élections qui vont
avoir lieu en décembre vont permettre de
fonder une nouvelle région et donc
celles et ceux qui vont y participer
vont rejoindre sûrement décisif pour les
années qu'il n'avait pas peur d'être
analysée par votre manque d'expérience
vous allez quand même piloté si vous
êtes élue la troisième région vient
effectivement
je découvre que je connais les aînés
vous savez que j'ai pas l'expérience
non vous emmener par le rediriger de
collectivités locales mais il sera
exempt il se trouve que non mais c'est
marrant parce que il se trouve que
l'activité principale en tout cas très
abondante et de travail avec vigueur
depuis des années j'ai dirigé un
observateur et terra jeunes de politique
j'ai été membre du comité de
centralisation du sénat pendant des
années je fais pas la liste j'ai pendant
des années de travail vers les
collectivités locales donc je n'ai pas
varié avec oui mais je les rejoigne j'ai
une bonne connaissance non
reconnaissance de leur douleur de leur
métier et de leurs problèmes et je ne
crois pas qu'on puisse exercer un mandat
sans avoir la légitimité la compétence
en démocratie elle vient de la
légitimité démocratique merci de
m'éclairer vous avez pu affûter vos
réponses à des questions qui viendront
pendant la campagne elles reviendront
pendant la campagne merci merci la
semaine prochaine notre invité sera
thierry mandon le secrétaire d'état à la
réforme de l'état bonsoir à tous et à
très vite
plus